Hey, you! You're finally awake. You were trying to cross the border, right?
Hello! Oh my goodness! Hello, hello, hello, welcome! Did you enjoy Mercy's dream? It's
nice to see you're still in one piece after Mercy, because, you know, after you're done
with me, there won't be anything left of you big brother. I'm just kidding. So in order
to introduce myself to you, I wanted to do a house tour. I cleaned up just before this,
okay? So I can promise you, you won't find anything sus in there. Okay, here we are,
totally not in Minecraft. This is real life. Don't be scared. You can hold my hand. I know
it's dark. It's a little scary. Oh my god! What is this? Is this a wanted poster for me?
And it's so close to my cabin too. What the heck? Okay, well, you know, I guess I can use this to
probably introduce myself to you. So, obviously, my name is Amy Beezoo. So my parents named me Amy
after the Japanese word for Imoto, which means sister. And Beezoo is the French word for kiss.
What a strange name they chose. Oh, by the way, ignore the crimes part. Okay, that's made up,
okay? So my hey, I'm 140 centimeters tall, but like I said before, I'm still growing, okay?
I'll be as tall as Azura one day. Just you wait. And then my birthday is April 10th. I hope you'll
be able to make it to my birthday party when the time comes. Otherwise, I might have to drag you
there myself. And my age is unknown. Yep, I've officially beaten the 800-year-old Lollie allegations
because I have no age. My language is okay. Obviously, you can tell that I'm fluent in English,
but I also speak a little bit of French. Let me show you my French.
Sacré bleu. Baguette. Are you going to finish that croissant? I'm kidding. Okay, obviously,
I'm kidding. Bonjour. Merci pour venir à mon débit. Je sais que mon accent ne pas bien, okay? Je ne
veux pas voir dans le chat que mon accent est terrible. Merci beaucoup. Je sais que les Québécois
ont commencé à déjà taper que je devrais sauter d'un pont parce que mon français fait saigner
à l'air. That's it again. Okay, moving on. Let's make our way to my house now.
So, this first room here is my hobby room. I got a lot of hobbies. Yep, I consider myself to be
a jack-of-all-trades and a master of none, except for baiting. Let me bring your attention here
to this desk. So, this is our whiteboard where I've written down our twitter.com tags. My Oshi
mark is a pumpkin and a band-aid. Surprise. My general, my general hashtag is a hashtag
Uwo, Uwo, Uwo, Imi, and all capital. Don't forget it. Thank you. Our meme hashtag is Beezoo. Our
art hashtag is Drot Imi. Our NSFW hashtag is Kimochimi. If you know Japanese, it's like, you know,
feeling good, Imi. Okay, our fan name is Pin Pals. I stole that from online. Credit to the person
who suggested Pin Pals online. And over here is my writing station. Yeah, I'm a writer. That's
right. I'm a woman of many talents. I like to write a little, a few of my ASMR scripts, and I also
just like to write for my own enjoyment. Yeah. Why don't we take a look at what I'm currently working
on here? Oh my god. I didn't know that was there. That wasn't supposed to be there. Okay, pretend
you never saw that. Moving on. So I'm an artist. Here's my little art station. Here's the drawing
I made. I actually designed the, the Pin Pals myself. So this is, this is the Pin Pals. Oh,
so cute. Don't mind me gassing myself up. Okay, let me, let me show you my art skills. You're
going to have to try to guess what I'm drawing. Okay, here I go. Guess what I'm drawing.
Oh, what could it be? What could it be? Did you guess? That's right. It's a dog.
Guys, you have such a dirty mind. I would, I would never draw that during debut. Oh my goodness.
Let's move on to this, this next room up here. I have my rat room.
That's right. I got four rats. I know it's hard to tell, but we are in Minecraft right now.
So you will see them for real in real life during my hand cam streams. Okay, so right across this
beam here, I have my bedroom. Ignore the blood on the floor. I mean, the red paint on the floor.
And over here's my little desk with my pewter. Yes. I'm here. I have my steam library open. I
know some of you might feel a little scared right now looking at these games. Valorant,
like legends. She's a loser version. What the fuck? I'm not a gamer. Okay. Your sister is not a gamer.
I will be playing that many games, but these are the games that I want to try eventually.
Will I even get to all of them? I don't even know. So here on this blackboard, I have my goals.
Yep, I've written down my goals. And the most important goal is to, to not give up.
I'm a very fragile soul. Okay. If you leave one hate comment, I'm leaving. I'm ending stream.
Next, I want to experiment with lots of different types of content. So a lot of ASMR tropes. I want
to try clip compilations. I want to try making memes. I even want to try singing. Oh, fuck.
Okay, moving on. I want to do a 3D debut. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm really excited for a 3D debut.
I want to touch the other viola girls in 3D. I want to sniff their booties. I want to grope them,
you know, basically everything you've ever wanted to do to them. I'll be able to do for you. Maybe
VR. Fourth is I want to make you happy. My ultimate goal is to entertain you, to make you laugh,
and to suck and fuck you. Okay, we're done here in my room. Let me, let me go down here. This is
my living room. This is where I do all my jorgen. Over here is my, my TV with a Netflix open. My
favorite shows. I really, really like kids cartoons, like old kids cartoons. I rewatch like all those
shows back to back constantly. So my favorite anime is a freerun, dungeon meshi, psyche is a huge
comfort anime of mine. Watamote. The main character is literally me. I really like houseman castle
and maiden abyss. Oh my goodness. I'm so sorry. Would you look at that? My, my coffee table is
such a mess. Oh, oh, it looks like the rats must have been messing with my stuff because apparently
they ripped up my diary. How rude of them. Well, I guess I can open up to you a little bit and show
you my thoughts, my feelings. Oh, I wrote my first impressions here. Okay. So for Mercy, she's very
social. She knows a lot of people like holy crap. And she's also very sweet. And her laugh is insane.
When I first heard her laugh, I was like, God damn. Next is I see she's God's ebius soldier.
And she's also effortlessly cute. Like I heard her yawn once and I was like, God damn. I have to try
to be cute. Okay. All of this cuteness you see in front of you is like practice, but I see it doesn't
even have to try scrawny is super, super caring. And she's also a nonstop gamer. And yeah, I don't
know how she plays games for so long. Like it couldn't be me. I'm jealous. I want to sit down and
play for that long, but I can't. Next is she be she'd be super funny. She's very hyper. You might
not notice that she's hyper during her debut. But once you get to know her more, yeah, she's also
very good at voice impressions. We were watching a stream together, and she copied the streamer's
voice. And I was so surprised because I couldn't tell if it was she be talking or the streamer.
And finally, we have a zero zero super, super chill. She's also good. A lot of games, all the
like community games we played together. She like when all of them and her voices is just pure sex.
So before we end, let me turn the camera back on to myself and I can show you my model. Yep. So
first I have this, you know, little shy arm pose. You know, when I'm feeling shy. I have these
love eyes, POV. I'm standing above you while you're sleeping. I have a exclamation point.
I have this one. We'll move past that one. That's for different streams, not for YouTube streams.
I can cry. I can be stupid. I mean, I'm always stupid, but I can look stupid. I can drool at.
I bet you want to lick that off my mouth, don't you? I can blush. I can be angry. You know,
I'll get on my bad side. I'll punish you. I can be scared and double scared and also sweaty.
I bet you want to lick my sweat too, huh? I've been reading your comments. I know. I can sleep.
I can take off my jacket. There it is. And you know what else I can take off? Oh, it's my shoes.
I can take my shoes off and I can stomp on you.
Oh, I think I missed one toggle. There we go. I can cast spells. Shadow Wizard Money Gang.
We please come along with me to a cliff under a tree.